You aren't making as much money as you
want because you don't know how to get
it from the people who've got it. My
name's Alex Hormozi. I run a portfolio
of companies at acquisition.com that
generate over $250 million per year. I
did a book launch 12 weeks ago that did
$106 million in sales in a weekend and
broke a Guinness World Record for the
fastest-selling nonfiction book of all
time. In this video, I'm going to
explain a core shift in my understanding
of how getting money actually works and
why the rich do in fact get richer, and
I'm going to show you the math behind
it, and most importantly, how you can
gain access to it.
The first reason that you aren't making
as much as you want is because you're
selling to people who don't have the
money to give you. So, think about it
like this, and this is really important.
Imagine this pyramid as a representation
of earning in the United States. What
percentage of the people do you think
earn 40% of the income?
The top 10% earn 40% of the income in
the entire US. Now, that's income, and
that's pretty extreme, but it's not even
close to the difference when you look at
wealth. So,
US household net worth, okay, this is
the value of their assets,
last year was 100
and 63 trillion dollars. And you're
like, "Man, how am I going to pay rent?"
I'm like, "Let's get some of that 163
trillion." So, this is going to blow
your mind.
So, I want you to imagine that you had
$100, okay? So, I'm going to equate this
163 trillion is now $100, okay? And
we're going to spread it out
relative to how it actually is spread
within the United States. So, this is
100 people to represent 100 percentiles
in terms of net worth in the United
States. This 163 trillion dollars, what
would they have if there was 100 people
to represent this $100?
They would have $2.50.
I'm just going to use bills cuz I don't
feel like having change. So, $2 out of
that 100, the bottom 50. So, the next
40%, what do you think they would have?
They're going to have 20
25 28 bucks.
That's the next 40. Remember, we got
$100 to distribute here.
So, the next 9%. So, now we're getting
in the top 10, the top decile of net
worth in the United States. How much do
you think they got?
They got 20
They got 30
They got 35
They got 38. All right, $38
in just this 9%.
Now
You ready for the the drumroll?
How much do you think the top 1% has?
I mean, it's 1/10, right? So, like it
can't be more than the other nine. What,
right? I mean, that you you think that.
The top one, just the one guy
would have 30
$2.
One guy.
Now, this means
that this one guy
has more
than the bottom 90% combined.
This is very important because it has
implications for how you do business.
So, when you hear me say sell to the
rich, they pay better, it's not some
pithy statement. It's reality, and it
takes people a very long time to learn
this. And people often take years before
they actually start to figure this out.
Usually, there's belief issues. They're
like, no one else could do this. And
part of the reason is because everyone
they know is poor. And they're like,
there's no way I could sell something
for that price. And so, they make stuff
against all the other small businesses
to compete for these $2. Think about
that for a second. You're putting all
the resources cuz you see all these
people. They're the ones that you're
brushing shoulders with. They're the
ones that you see in the street every
single day. And you're trying to compete
and slice these $2 a hundred different
ways.
Right?
If you want to make money,
go where the money is.
So, let's put this concept on steroids
now and actually apply this to doing
business. This is how big companies get
big. They go where the money's at, and
this is a breakdown of somebody called
Prato's principle. You might have heard
of it, 80/20. It's one of the most
powerful concepts in business, and most
people still don't understand how to
actually apply it. All right, so I want
you to freeze this idea in your head.
Just look at the money here. $2 here, 28
bucks here, 38 here. Now we're in the
top 10%, right? And we have another 32
here. So I said earlier that this one
guy is more than the bottom 90.
But 69%
of all the wealth is just in these 10
people.
If this doesn't change how you do
business,
you are missing the plot. So the idea of
80/20 is that Prato, who was Italian
economist, realized that there was this
you know, 20% of customers created 80%
of the revenue.
Uh and he just noticed this 80/20, you
know, kind of issue that continued to
occur within all different types of data
sets.
And so that became his principle. Now,
here's where this gets really
interesting.
So within business, it totally rings
true where 20% of your customers will be
responsible for 80% of your profits. And
then here's where people miss the next
point, is that within this 80
within this 80%
64%
percent of the aggregate profit, right?
Comes from just 4%
of the
There you go, I'll just do that. of the
people in there. Four customers, if you
had 100.
And then of this 64
51% of the profit comes from just the
top 1%.
Now doesn't that all of a sudden start
to make sense when you look at how the
wealth is distributed? That the wealth
is distributed in a way that also makes
sense that the business would get in its
profits in that way.
And so, we repeat this process and this
is kind of power law within business.
This is how you do less and make more.
Profit takes into account the fact that
a single person, even with more service,
often doesn't cost that much more to
handle than the other 99. So, it's more
work but significantly more profitable.
Now, this is only true under one very
important condition. That you actually
have a business model that allows them
to pay more. Right? If you just only
charge $10 for your thing,
like this is one of my favorite sayings
is the only thing worse than offering a
$1,000 thing to somebody who's got a
$100 budget is offering a $100 thing to
somebody who's got a $1,000 budget. In
the first scenario, you lose 100 bucks.
In the second, you lose 900.
Big difference. And so, here's the
important thing. If you have a model
that allows for that, you have to
understand that 99 out of 100 people are
not the top 1%, right? If we're pulling
back here,
all these people are not the top 1%. So,
you should expect them to say no to your
expensive products and services. But
when that whale comes, you should want
to Captain Ahab that and get it
done. Real quick, I'm going to show you
the exact 10-stage roadmap from zero to
100 million plus that less than 1% of
companies finish I've now done multiple
times. And so, I can say with a lot of
confidence that these are the stages as
head count increases that you need to
get through and I broke each of these
down by eight different functions of the
business, what the constraint feels
like, like what are the symptoms of it
when you're going through it, and then
what steps we actually took to graduate.
And we've done this across software,
physical products, uh service
businesses, brick and mortar, all of
this and it works. And it's my gift to
you. It's absolutely free. And so, the
link's in the description, but you just
go acquisition.com/roadmap.
Just enter your info and it'll spit it
right back to you all free.
And so, the reason that I talk about
selling to these the top 1% is that
one of the most effective ways to build
a business is from the top down.
So, what do I mean by that? Like think
about like Tesla, right? We started with
a $250,000 Roadster and he had a very
limited production. Very few people,
more profitability per. What then
happens? Well, then he was able to make
the, you know, Model S and that was the
next car. And then he made the Model 3
or Model Y, whatever. So, he kept
working his way down. But what's
interesting about this is that when you
anchor high, it makes sense think about
from a branding narrative perspective.
If I say, "Hey, I've got this really
expensive car. It's amazing. It's super
fast." And then I say, "Hey guys, many
of you couldn't afford this, so I made
another car that's similar, but more
affordable for you."
That that brand narrative works because
you've anchored high. Now, think about
the reverse. Hey, I'm a I'm a budget
discounter and I'm going to now sell a
really expensive car. It doesn't It
doesn't hit the same, right? And so, I
love the top-down approach because you
have a brand reinforcer, but also from
an operational perspective,
being able to ship the amount of cars he
has to ship for the the Model 3 compared
to the amount that he had to do for the
Roadster, it made more sense to start
here cuz you can handle the volume,
right? You might not have the operations
to handle the amount of work that it
requires to serve the masses. Like for
sure, there is money, right? At the
bottom, there is. But you have to be
doing it at very small razor-thin
margins with extraordinary volume. And
unless you have the capital to create
something that truly scales to that
mass, you will probably just end up
trying to squeeze the $2 for more than
what what they're worth. And so, how do
we actually translate this into pricing
our products and services? This is super
important.
So, here's my rule of thumb for upsells
taking to account that 20% of customers
have far more spending power than the
ones below. Now, remember, we had $2
here and the next level had 28. So, it
was 14 times more wealth between just
the bottom 50 and the next 40. But just
using the Pareto principle in terms of
how we can apply this to pricing, like
you not understanding this is why your
business is not making as much profit as
you want, all right? So, my rule of
thumb is that for every new tier
is that
you want to 5 to 10x your price
and expect 20% of people to take it.
Okay?
So, here's how it works. So, let's say
that you sell 10 customers, okay? So,
you tell 10 customers, do do do. Let's
do it again.
Okay?
Now, if you have eight of these
customers
at $10 per month
and you've got two of them at $50 per
month
how much am I making on these guys? I'm
making $80 per month in total
on the bottom 80 and then I'm making
$100 per month
on my top 20% or my top two. And so, by
serving these two customers differently,
we double the revenue of the business,
which by the way, again, is my rule of
thumb. I want each tier
to bring me another double, like another
full amount of revenue. Otherwise, I'm
like, I don't know if it's worth
creating the actual extra constraint of
operations, right? But, here's where it
gets even nastier. Let's say that this
covers the majority of our overhead.
That means that this extra $100 might
contribute 10 to 1
compared to this to our bottom line. And
so, sometimes when you make a move like
this, if you were here and you had $80
and you were living your life on this
80, right? It's like, well, maybe your
your your cost is 70 or you're taking 10
home. If you add this $100 in and maybe
the cost on this is 20, you've got 80
left over, we 5x the profit. So, let's
say our profit before this was 10 a
month.
And then we add this in and we had $80 a
month in profit from this 100, right?
Look at the difference in profit. We go
from 10
to 90.
Just by adding this tier. And so, the
reason your business is not making as
much money, and you're not making as
much money as you want, is because
you're not priced appropriately for the
people who actually have the money to
give you. And so, to maximize revenue,
you can think of it with four tiers of
pricing. And to be clear, you don't need
to serve everyone, and the first product
you have may not be your base tier. All
right, so you might start here. I don't
know yet. I don't know your business.
But, this is what you can walk through
in terms of thinking through the pricing
for your products and services. So,
let's assume that we have 1,000
customers, all right? So, on our on our
our base tier, all right, so this is the
lowest,
$10 per month, and let's say we've got
800 customers at this level, okay? Now,
our second tier, we might have it $100
per month, so 10 times that price, with
20% taking it, all right? So, that means
we're going to get somewhere in the
neighborhood of 200-ish people who would
qualify for this tier. Okay. And the
next tier, we still have to follow our
rule, 5 to 10x. That means we're going
to be at 500 to 1,000 a month for this
next tier. Just to keep it simple, I'm
going to just do 10x, cuz it's
nice and clean. All right? And so, here,
we're going to have maybe
around 40. Now, you're like, wait, I
thought we had 1,000 customers. This
will be 160. I'll redo the math in
advance so you can see it. All right?
Now, our next tier might be, again, 5 to
10 times this, and so it might be
somewhere in this 5 to 10,000 a month,
all right? And so,
times around eight people. Okay?
And so, if you're looking at this,
you're like, holy cow, that's uh those
are very big differences in price. Yes,
but so they they reflect how different
the spending power that exists within
customers is. All right? And so, the
main takeaway from this and is that if
you're going to have an upsell, a very
small percentage people are going to
take it. And so you have to make it
worth it. And so people will have these
I'll go 100 and 129. It's like it's the
same pitch. It's the same price. The
willingness to pay for that customer is
the same. Let me show you how I've
actually translated this into my own
business. All right? Well, this and you
can ignore the actual numbers of
customers, but what do we have here?
Ah.
We have school. And then at a $100 a
month, what else do we have? We have
school. This is our hobby plan.
This is our pro plan.
And so for me, the next number
is $5,000.
Which is L1.
And what's the next number after that?
$35,000.
Huh? Almost like it's between five to 10
times the price, which is L2.
And then what do we have after that? We
have something that's $135,000.
So that's four times the price, right?
And this is L3. And what do we have
underneath of that?
No money because it's a portfolio
company.
And so the thing is is it may take some
time to build out this entire thing. I
didn't start with school. I started
building, you know, you know, our brand.
This is to be clear just our advisory
practice
that we have at acquisition.com.
And so I'm just saying like knowing this
doesn't mean you need to do all of this
at once. It takes years and it does take
operational chops to pull this off,
right? You want to add tiers one at a
time. My tip though is to start as high
up as you can on this ladder for a few
reasons, right? So the Tesla example I
gave earlier, the branding from top down
versus bottom up is much stronger. Like
Honda making a better car is tough
versus Rolls-Royce making a Rolls-Royce
light. It would be easier play for them
from brand position.
The next reason is that I prefer to
start with the unscalable. Why? Because
it's easier to operationalize it serving
these people because one, they actually,
believe it or not, as a percentage of
their net worth, this is actually lower
than what this is for somebody who's
poor. Right? If you have uh $10
100 grand is 1% of what you've got. If
you've got $1,000
100 bucks is 10% of what you got. And so
for you, you will actually be more
demanding for that 10 that 10% of that
$100 reasonably so than somebody who's
giving 1%. But from a business
perspective, the 100 bucks versus the
100 grand, it's a gigantic difference.
You have an easier customer to deal with
that has lower demandingness, but it
requires and to be clear, to get that
$100 to equal $100,000 is you got to get
a thousand of those people. So is
serving the one customer for $100,000
easier than serving a thousand at a
hundred? As somebody used to sell $100
gym memberships, for sure.
And if we were to look at this from a
profit contribution perspective, like
what is actually dropping to the bottom
line,
it would look like this.
All the profit is here. Just like all
the wealth is at the top.
So you have to do more and charge more
for it to people who can afford it. And
the amount you do for a few people is
almost always worth it for the far
greater price for those people who are
willing to pay it. Now, you might ask,
"Well, wait a second. I thought you said
sell to the rich. Like why do you have
this $10 and this $100 monthly?"
The only way to serve the poor masses,
right? And I say this to be a little bit
more like, you know, jarring. But to to
to to serve people with lower budgets is
to have tons of money and then find a
way to serve them in an automated manner
at a low price. And if you do that, you
can also make a lot of money, but via
volume.
But it takes a lot of money. It takes a
lot of time. And the reason that Tesla
has almost gone bankrupt multiple times
is because it's incredibly hard. The
reason most software companies like
Netflix and Spotify and some of these
big consumer, you know, companies, uh
you know, who who charge $13 to give you
Think about how hard that is. Think
about hard that business is. You They
have to make world-class entertainment
for all the different genres that
someone might like just to earn their
$13,
right? Just to earn the equivalent of
like a Chipotle bowl.
And I again, I bring this up because
some people come in saying, "Oh, I'm
going to do that." It's like, "You're
going to do that bootstrapped?" No,
these companies that you're looking to
model literally got artificially
inflated with outside capital to prop
the business up until it would get to
the point where it actually could make
money. So, to do something like this
costs a fortune. And so, the the way
that I'm trying to walk you through this
is that 80% of businesses in the US or
78 are service-based businesses. And so,
you don't have an automated way to serve
these masses. You likely don't. And so,
if you don't have an automated way, then
you want to go in the complete other
direction, which is I want to serve the
best customer at the highest possible
price. But people misprice their
products and services. They say, "Okay,
I'm my you know, my current core thing
is $1,000. I'll make the next thing
$1,500." It doesn't work that way.
That's not how the buyer works. The
buyer is at 5K, 10K from the 1K thing.
That's the next tier. That's the next
rung on the ladder. All right? And so,
this hopefully should shift your
perspective in terms of how pricing
really works. A disproportionate amount
of profit is here. We have to make
gigantic jumps with the assumption that
very small percentages are going to take
it, but still be okay with it because
even a small number of people at a
gigantic price is still a lot of money.
So, how do you actually translate this
and put this into practice?
Number one, stop selling from your own
wallet. Especially if you're one of the
people who, you know, you're in that in
that $2 category, right? You're in that
bottom 50% right now. I get it. I've
been there.
You have to forever imagine. This is a
gift. Forever imagine that everyone is
rich. So, here's the reality that will
shock you. That top 10%
Top 10% of Americans
have a million-dollar plus net worth.
One in 10 people. One in 10 people.
Million-dollar net worth.
They've got the money.
You just aren't selling them something
that they want. And you might even be,
and this happens a lot, especially for
newer business owners, you might even be
too cheap for them to even believe that
you're good. Like, we had a company that
uh that was in the health space a while
back,
and looking at all the research, it was
a doctor and all the stuff, and
I just fundamentally believed that they
were mispriced. And so, what I did was I
raised I wanted to raise the price by
double. He fought me back and forth
forever, and I have I was able to
finally get a 50% price raise through.
But, guess what happened? We raised the
price by 50%. That's a lot. What do you
think it did to the close rates?
They went up. They were so cheap
compared to the promise and what they
were delivering that people didn't even
believe that it worked. And so, some of
you guys are so cheap because you're
selling out of your own wallet. You're
selling based on what your friends and
family, who might also be in that $2
bottom 50%
are telling you. But, why would you
listen to the people who don't have
money on how to get money? They don't
know where it is. They don't know how to
get it. And more specifically, they
don't know how to serve the people
who've got it.
So, that's the first thing.
The second thing is that if you're going
to do this,
listen to me on this.
Whatever your upsell is, 5 to 10x the
price. And then just make sure it's
something that you'd be happy to deliver
for 5 to 10 times the price. Sometimes
I'll get pushback from people who are
like,
"Ah, that would that would be so much
work." And I'm like, "Cool. We have
value, and we have price. Move one of
them. Either do less or charge more." I
would encourage you to just charge more.
Right? And so, if I were to say, "Hey, I
want you to 10 times the current price
of your upsell,
what would you do that would absolutely
blow people away?" How much does that
actually cost you when you look at the
cost compared to that 10 times bigger
price with a zero in the end of whatever
your core offer is, you might find it's
like, "Actually, it's only like, you
know, 5% of that price." It's like,
"Right. Really high margin."
So,
as long as you're happy making more
money serving fewer people, go do that.
The third one is that you should expect
only one in five or one in 10 people to
say yes. Expect more no's. And this is
the sweet spot of making money, right?
The sweet spot isn't the most yes's,
it's the most money. And that is never
with the most yes's. So if you pitch
your 10 times bigger price to this
bottom 50%, none of them are going to
say yes. And you're going to mistakenly
believe that this is a bad idea. But the
route is that you're not talking to the
people who have the money. And so you
should expect that if you have a
representative amount of people that you
speak with, one in 10, maybe even one in
100, is the is the person who is the
correct avatar. And for that person, you
might also find they'll just say like,
"Yeah, that sounds good." You'll be
like, "Oh my god." And I only say this
as somebody who's had it happen for the
first time, you're like, "I can't even
believe this is possible. I can't
believe this person would give me this
much money." It's cuz to them, it's not
that much money. It's only that much
money to you because you still live
here.
If you sell to rich people long enough,
they will make you one of them.
And so with your upsell, make it crazy.
And this is called an anchor for a
reason, right? If no one buys it, no big
deal. Or most don't, no big deal. But
the good news is that it'll still help
you sell the rest of everyone else at a
higher percentage and even at a higher
rate because it'll look like a good deal
in comparison.
And I said this before, but I'll say
this again.
The next reason is the only thing worse
than selling a $1,000 thing to a $100
buyer is selling a $100 thing to a
$1,000 buyer. In the first, you lose 100
bucks. In the second, you lose 900. And
not only that, that 900 is probably
disproportionately profit. And this is
what no one understands. This is why
most businesses don't make money. They
just try and sell to these people who
are the biggest pain in the butt. And
the thing is is you see so many of them
that you're like, "Oh, this must be how
it works." No, it's not how it works.
It's just how you're working. This is
how the average business works, which is
why the average business doesn't make
money.
They don't go to the where the money's
at.
The next reason is you have to think
about
absolute profit rather than relative
profit, and you'll be blown away. So, a
single person paying $10,000 for
something that cost $2,000.
A single person, right? One, right?
Buying a $10,000 thing
that cost $2,000
is the same
as
400 people
buying a $50 thing
that cost $25.
These are the same.
So, do not underestimate the power of
large prices and small quantities. And
so, the reason that entrepreneurship is
such almost like a spiritual journey is
that you you earn the right to charge
more because you no longer think the
smaller amount of money is worth your
time. There are beliefs that people who
have money have which translate to
behaviors that poor people don't have
and translate to different behaviors.
So, what does that mean?
A rich kid will choose not to pursue a
lower leverage opportunity because it's
not worth their time because they were
taught it wasn't worth their time. The
career paths that they'll have to choose
from will be significantly skewed
towards things where they'll get
disproportionate returns. And a lot of
that is just knowledge about it, not
even knowledge how to do it. I remember
when I first found out I'd never heard
of management consulting, I'd never
heard of private equity, I'd never heard
of investment I'd never heard of any of
this stuff when I went to college
because where I was from in Baltimore, a
rich person was a doctor. That was a
rich person. And so, and to be fair, my
dad's a doctor. So, I felt I was like,
okay, cool. When I went to Vanderbilt, I
felt like one of the poorest people
there because I'd never seen what New
York money was. I'd never seen what
California money was. I'd seen what
Baltimore rich was, which is that you
have, you know, my dad has a business
with two secretaries and you know, we
always had food. I never had to worry
about it. I still have the immigrant
mentality of like, we don't use, you
know, paper towels cuz they're
expensive, but like, that's just cuz he
came here with a thousand bucks. And I
that still got transmitted. In some
ways, you almost have to
you almost have to bat above you have to
hit above your weight class, right?
Which is even though it sounds un
like
in the story of when I actually made my
first high-ticket sale in my life was
when I I actually said a number that I
wanted the person to say no to.
And said yes. That was how that actually
that belief was broken for me. So, as
much as I want to say like, this is what
you have to do. I'm this guy, you know,
guy on YouTube that you just saw or
whatever. Like,
Leila and I were selling
we we started doing these gym launches.
We would sell memberships through gyms.
We would collect the money.
And that was the model. We'd fly around
the country. That's what we did.
There were some issues with that model,
which I've talked about in other videos.
And so, then all of a sudden, Leila
started selling weight loss directly,
made a little brand for her called Queen
Transformation. We started selling these
$500 online training packages
over the phone. And that started
working. And so, I had these gyms that I
was supposed to do these launches at
that I had decided I wasn't going to do
them anymore. And so, I had eight gyms I
was supposed to call up and like
basically cancel on them.
And so, on the first phone call, the guy
was actually a referral, and he was
like, "Dude, you saved my my friend's
gym. Like, I know you can do this." And
I I was so beat down at this point. I
was like, "Dude, I'm not like I I'm not
doing it." And he kept asking for it.
And then I finally I was like, "All
right, dude. Like, I'll show you what I
do,
but I'm not going to find out there to
help you if you can't close." And mind
you, I come from the done-for-you world
of like, I literally did everything. I
fronted the money. I fronted the cash. I
built, you know, I'd literally buy the
tables. I'd print the the contracts out.
I'd run the ads. We'd work the leads.
And we'd sell them straight in the gym.
So, I did everything. So, me saying that
was just I hoped that he would just like
say screw off. And he was like, "No, I
get it. I get it." And he was like,
"Well, how much?" And so, I said, and
remember, I'm used to selling $500
16-week training packages where you have
to show up like every, you know, three
times a week to do stuff.
I said $6,000. So, for me, it was a 12x
compared to the price that I was used to
selling at. And I just said it. So, I
was like, he's just going to say,
"Nope." And then I can just hang up and
just move on to my next call. And he
said, "6K?" And I was like, "Yeah."
$6,000.
And he was like,
"Done."
And I I remember like floating out of my
body in this moment being like,
"Holy Six
grand
from one call?"
And I didn't I didn't even have the
thing. I didn't even have the thing that
I had sold him yet, cuz I just didn't
think he was going to say yes. I didn't
think to have to build it, right? And
so, I was like, "Holy shit." And so,
then the next So, I had seven more
calls. I called the next guy, same
conversation. I was like, "Oh, now I got
to build this thing." But, it went
really smooth. I was like,
Uh he was like, "How much?" I was like,
"Eight grand." He was like, "Yeah,
done." And I was like, "Eight grand." I
was like, "I'm up $14,000 in a I'm not
even in a day. It's in a morning." So,
then I had six more calls. And by the
end of the You know, the next call, same
thing. How much? 10K. Next call
And by the end of the day, I'd done
$60,000
in in collected. And I was like,
"What
the just happened?"
I had no idea what was going on.
Uh and so, Leila came back after she was
selling the $500 memberships. And I was
like, "Babe." I was like, "I just made
60 grand." And she was like,
"What?"
She was like, I She was like, "I thought
we were doing the weight loss thing." I
was like, "No, I didn't We're still
doing the gym thing. I think we're just
doing it wrong."
And this is why I'm telling you this,
cuz like that moment, of all the moments
in my entire career, that was the moment
where I elevated.
That was the moment where my life really
changed.
And so,
I bring this up because you might be
like, "Well, what At what price point
should I start?" Right? It's going to be
relative whether you're selling to
consumers or selling to businesses. And
these are just a couple rules of thumb
that I'll just tell you that I've kind
of worked around. I'd say that for um
for a consumer, an impulse purchase is
five or six hundred dollars. A higher
ticket purchase is usually going to be
somewhere between three and ten thousand
dollars, right? Typically. And that's
again for services. If you're looking at
like assets, it's a different game.
You're buying houses and cars, it's a
different game, right? But if you're
selling just like pure I'm going to help
you do some stuff. I'm going to help fix
some stuff.
That's usually a price point that's
quite higher ticket. Business, it really
depends on the size business. If you're
selling to Disney, you can sell a
billion dollar thing, right? If you're
selling to just small business owners
on Main Street. Remember, some of them
are poor, too, right? And so for them
though,
you know, a more normal price for
something will probably be somewhere in
the neighborhood of like I'd say like a
mid-tier is probably, you know, two to
three thousand dollars a month. A
cheaper price for a business owner would
be somewhere in the neighborhood of like
four hundred to eight hundred a month.
Maybe maybe just call call call it
closer to five hundred bucks a month
as like a a cheaper number for a
business. And you're like, five hundred
dollars a month is cheap for a business.
It's like, yeah, super expensive for a
consumer, pretty cheap for a business,
right? One of the big issues I'd say
that poor people think about compared to
rich people is that poor people will
think in terms of cost and I would say
rich people will think in terms of the
ratio, the return, cost versus value. So
if I were to say, "Hey, I've got this
thing that's let's say it's let's say
it's twenty thousand dollars."
A poor person just hearing the price
would say, "That's expensive."
But if I said a rich person, if I said,
"Hey, my thing is twenty thousand
dollars." They wouldn't then say,
"That's expensive." They'd say, "For
what?"
And if I said,
uh
share a class A share of Berkshire
Hathaway, which is an eight hundred
thousand dollar stock for twenty
thousand dollars, that would be the deal
of the century, right? If I said it was
twenty thousand dollars for a brand new
Lamborghini, they would say, "That's a
great deal." So even though it costs a
lot of money, it's great value. And this
is what I did I struggled for such a
long time to understand because it was
like I almost had this emotional
reaction to zeros. It's like if I saw
zeros, I was like, "Oh my god, it's so
much, right?" And and so I know where
you're coming from because you almost
want to you almost choke on the price.
So, I'll give you a couple little
tactics for this to like get around it.
So, one is if you're in person, you can
write down the price and then turn it
and slide it to them. Uh or you can use
a calculator and turn it to them if you
like literally choke on the price cuz
some people do do that.
Um
the second thing that you can do, and
this is a really good little little
pricing hack for for selling, is before
you say the price, you say, "Hey, before
I tell you the price, it's super
expensive."
And so, what's beautiful about telling
someone it's expensive before you tell
them the price is that if someone's
rich, they're going to immediately think
what's expensive for them.
And so, they're going to think a number
and then you're going to say the number
and they're going to they're going to
literally be like, "Ah,
fine." If they're poor and you say it's
expensive, they're going to brace
themselves for a number that's big. And
then when you give them that number,
they were at least embraced for it. And
so, in either way, you actually create
what I would consider an emotional
anchor that's perfectly accommodating to
the buying power of the prospect. And
most sales people get choked up right at
that point. So, it's like give yourself
a breather. It's going to be expensive.
You take a breath, they take a breath,
then you deliver, right? So, it's just a
little tactic that works and also can
help increase sales. So, a good way to
know if you're actually under priced is
to actually look at your close rates,
all right? And so, if your close rates
are 80% or let's say 60 to 80, I'll put
this in tiers for you. Um
50 to 60
40 to 50 and then 30 to 40 and then 30.
Okay. So, let's say these are your close
rates.
So, that means if you talk to 10 people,
here you close eight, right? If you're
closing 80%, you probably right now have
a two to three X in pricing, sorry, a
three to four X in pricing, excuse me. A
three to four X in pricing just sitting
there. I know that sounds absurd, but
think about it. You're going to get the
80% are not going to say yes anymore. I
want to be very clear. You might drop to
like 35%, but if 35% of people are
paying four times more, you're making
120% of the revenue that you were making
before. All right, and so like you were
making way more money.
Now, at 60 80, you probably have a two
to three X that you have sitting there
in price. If you're between 50 and 60,
you probably have a 1.5 X to two X
sitting there. If you're at 40 to 50%,
you're probably at 1.25 to 1.5 X. All
right, if you're here, I consider this
to be appropriately priced. If you're
closing 30 to 40%, you're priced about
right. If you're below 30, I would say
get better at selling.
Which part of getting better at selling
can be make the offer better or talk to
better customers. All right, and so
sometimes you will try and pitch a high
ticket thing, but not have your core
offer, which might be lower, so you have
an anchor offer. Um,
but the people that you're speaking with
you didn't qualify them. So, if I want
to say, "Hey, I'm talking to million
dollar plus business owners." I will
have a significantly higher close rate
if I'm only talking to them.
So, all of what I described is something
called lead scoring or lead
qualification.
And so, what that means is that there's
a certain type of customer that's more
likely to buy your thing, right?
Somebody who has more money is more
likely to to buy your more expensive
thing. And so, if we know that the
people who have the money are the ones
that buy our expensive thing, then we
should try and just tell the world we
only cater to these people. Now,
the next thing that will come up is
people will say, "Hey,
I would sell for a really expensive
thing, but no one will buy it because
there's guys down the street who will
sell it for less because they're broke
you selling to broke you." You're right.
And that's because you can't sell the
same thing. You got to sell something
different. Which is why I wrote my first
book on this. which is the first chapter
is you're selling a commodity. You're
selling something that someone could
reasonably hold your thing and their
thing up and say, "These two things are
the same, so I'll just pick the cheaper
one." And that's reasonable for them to
do it. The idea is that we want to price
our things so high and be in such a
clearly different category that people
say, "These two things must be
different. I have to analyze these
independently." And so, within the
context of what do I get for my money,
the rich person wants three things. They
want it to be fast, they want it to be
easy, and they want it to be guaranteed.
And so, everything that you do that is
more difficult for these people, you
have to make easier, and these people
will be willing to pay for it. And so,
you pre-do some of that work for them.
You pre-chew some of the food. You go
ahead of time, you drive ahead, you
scout the location, you drive it to the
door, whatever it is. But when you look
at, "Well, what does it cost for me to
drive this thing to the door?" It cost
me 10 bucks, but they're willing to pay
100 for it.
Whereas this person's nagging me on the
last five bucks.
It's a different game, but this is where
all the money's at.
The reality of how services work is that
you can tell how advanced a service
business owner is by how expensive their
product is. Because if you're actually
good, you have more demand than you have
supply. If you have more demand than you
have supply, what should you do? Raise
price. That's how the supply-demand
curve works. And so, you continue to
raise your price until you're at a point
where you're at equilibrium, where like
you can handle the amount of demand that
you have. If you're still good, you
still get more demand because word of
mouth continues, and you keep going up,
and that becomes the virtual virtuous
cycle of price and services. Because
when you have a higher price, you have
higher gross margins. You have higher
gross margins, you can hire better
talent. When you have had better talent,
you can deliver better services. You
have better service, you get better
reputation. You have better reputation,
what does that do? Drives demand.
Which then drives price.
And so, this is the cycle that every
business has to go through. And you
signal to the marketplace, you
communicate to the marketplace. Pricing
is a two-way communication. You tell
them what you're about, and then they
will self-select as the correct
customers for you.
And so, So can see where someone's at in
their business journey by how high they
are priced compared to people who sell
comparable services because people will
very much take price as an indication of
value.
They just do because in general things
that are priced higher are better.
Not always
but often. It's a good enough rule of
thumb that people in general will do
that.
Like
this might blow your mind if you've like
not met people with money.
When they go to shop at a store, they
price from high to low.
They literally look at the most
expensive stuff first
cuz that's probably the stuff that's for
them.
They don't want you save money anymore.
They want to get better value. They want
better stuff. They want to skip the
line. They want to get it faster. They
want it better. They want it to be a
higher quality you know higher quality
ingredients. They want it to be more
made by somebody who's more noteworthy
all of these things.
And fundamentally that is what this book
goes into tremendous detail talking
about which is the offers book. All
right.
So with that being said
sell to the rich, they pay better.
It's better to sell fewer expensive
customers than many broke customers.
And if you sell to rich people for long
enough, they will make you one of them.